nearly everything we buy is made
overseas no matter where you live it's
likely the majority of products you use
on a daily basis are made outside your
own country's borders even at the
supermarket it's common to see fresh
food that was grown or caught on the
other side of the world not long ago
this would've been unheard of everything
had to be produced close to the consumer
it just wasn't profitable to ship goods
over long distances only luxury and
specialty items were shipped from
overseas very few common place items
were produced more than a couple hundred
miles away from the final market that
all changed on April 26 1956 when the
ideal ex a converted World War 2 tanker
left Newark New Jersey on its main
journey what was so special about this
journey was that it was the first time
in history that a ship had its cargo
packed into containers rather than just
loosely placed throughout its holds this
seems like a simple and uninfluential
concept but this idea changed our world
before the ideal ex cargo was brought to
port in trucks and loaded onto ships
piece by piece whiskey and rice and
hammers and everything was packed
tightly into the hold and the whole
loading process took more than a week
this technique known as breakbulk cargo
dated back to the time of the
Phoenicians it was said that dock
workers wages were $20 a day and all the
Scotch you could carry home because the
theft of goods was so rampant this
needed to change Malcolm McLean a
trucking company owner sold everything
he owned to buy a ship and developed the
system of containerization unbearably
simple he designed a corrugated steel
box and created some trucks and a ship
that would seamlessly hold these boxes
disconnected the manufacturer straight
to the consumer manufacturers would load
these boxes then no hands would touch
the merchandise into the container with
delivered to the vendor distributor or
consumer one of the most amazing aspects
of this system is that it became
universal
we can't even agree on a currency plug
type DVD standard or even which side of
the road to drive on but we can agree
across the world on the one size of
shipping container a container loaded in
Kansas will fit on the train that takes
it to the dock then fit on the boat that
takes it to China then fit on the truck
that will take it up to Russia even some
planes are now being designed to fit
intermodal containers there's no need
for logistics no need for calculations
no need for worrying if the container
will work in faraway countries but what
really changed our world was how quick
this system made the loading process of
a ship what used to take more than a
week could now be done in a matter of
hours shipping costs plummeted after the
introduction of this system whole cities
such as Newark and Oakland were put on
the map because of their new larger
ports that were needed in response to
the shipping boom this system also
helped create the global economy that we
have today one where one car has
elements from dozens of countries across
the world it's now cheaper to
manufacture many goods on the other side
of the world because shipping is so
inexpensive containerization was the
greatest driver of the development of a
global economy and trade network the
intermodal container cut shipping time
from Europe to Australia down from 70 to
34 days without increasing the speed of
travel we are still witnessing the
aftermath of this innovation today
between 1993 and 2002 the average
distance of a Cargo shipment grew by 40%
this means that goods are still being
manufactured farther and farther away
from their market the value per ton of
cargo is also dropping more and more
cheap items are being shipped from far
away to be sold however many believe
that containerization could have been
the last great innovation and shipping
boats can't really go any faster while
still being profitable 15 knots is the
average speed today for cargo ships and
it's unlikely that this speed will
increase in the near future
to make shipping faster and cheaper one
needs to find other ways to speed up the
process there are some small changes
being developed such as the automation
of ports and further specialization of
ships however the greatest innovation
for shipping may come from the greatest
threat to mankind
global warming is opening new routes for
shipping the once frozen Northeast
Passage north of Scandinavia and Russia
now can be sailed on for a few months of
the year in 2009 a German cargo ship
became the first commercial vessel to
sail this route and today multiple ships
use this route every year the route
shortens the shipping time between
Europe and Asia by days avoids the
pirate-infested waters of the Red Sea
and Gulf of Aden and saves on average
300,000 dollars in fuel per vessel per
voyage so there you have it that's how a
metal box changed our world without that
box we wouldn't have our phones from
China our clothes from Bangladesh or
even our oranges from Florida tipping is
a behind-the-scenes process that has
made our world what it is today
our economy and our lies would not be
the same without this innovation
containerization may be little known but
its effects are more evident than almost
any other invention of the 20th century